game and it looks like that's going to
happen any second house still with how
many how much time 18 yard up to 16
minutes 16 and 17 i need to get some
glasses
i mean that's still a lot of time yeah
more time than he started with which is
like he's made it look easy so uh i mean
i was talking about confidence for the
young players but look at these guys
nippomiachi and ronia and they all play
instantly these days yeah trusting their
instincts that's another key thing in
chess yeah we've seen this position
before yeah just going round in circles
now just playing it out so well how
impressed are you guys bayana pomnyacci
in this tournament he seems almost
invincible yeah and he seems calm that's
the main thing yeah in the world
championship match we commentated on he
was never really calm in the second half
at least
but he's got that kindness back and
that's the key yeah yeah i think it's a
confidence thing isn't it i mean it
happens all the time chess is a is a
mind sport game and you've got to you've
got okay is that a draw that is a draw
that is the draw and jana pognati is the
first player that is ready for air
things monsters semi-fight